here in glasgow
we see the promise of further progress
what is also true
is that collectively and individually
we are still falling short
we have not done nearly enough to
address this crisis
we are going to have to do more
and whether that happens or not to a
large degree
is going to depend on you
not just those of you in this room
but anybody who's watching
or reading a transcript of what i say
here today
that was true six years ago as well
you know in paris our goal was to turn
progress
into an enduring framework that would
give
the world confidence in a low-carbon
future
an agreement where countries would
update their emissions targets on a
regular basis
an agreement that would help developing
nations get the resources they need
to skip the dirty phase of development
and help
those nations that are most vulnerable
to climate change get the resources they
need to adapt
an agreement that would give businesses
and investors the certainty
that the global economy is on a firm
path towards a clean and sustainable
future
in other words
our hope was to create an agreement that
gave our planet a fighting chance
that was our ambition
and by some measures
the agreement
has been a success
for the first time leaders of nearly 200
nations large and small
developed and developing made a
commitment to work together to confront
a threat
to the people of all nations
and that seemed proof that for all the
divisions in our world when a crisis
threatens all of us we can come together
to address it
at the time we also believe that if
enough national governments showed they
were serious
about climate
then other institutions particularly in
the private sector
would start raising their sites as well
and over the last six years
that is what's happened today more than
one-fifth of the world's largest
companies have set net zero emissions
targets
not just because it's the right thing to
do for the environment
but in many cases because it makes sense
for their bottom line
more than 700 cities in more than 50
countries
have pledged to cut their emissions in
half by the end of the decade
and reach net zero by 2050.
about a third
of the global banking sector has agreed
to align their work with the paris
agreement
so that's meaningful now
back in the united states of course
some of our progress stalled when my
successor decided to unilaterally pull
out of the paris agreement in his first
year in office
i wasn't real happy about that
and yet
the determination
of our state and local governments
along with the regulations and
investment that my administration had
already put in place allowed our country
to keep moving forward
despite hostility from
the white house
the 90 billion dollar investment that we
made in 2009 helped to jumpstart the
clean energy industry in the united
states and markets adapted and so did
consumers
and even when
the trump administration rolled back
emissions requirements for automakers
along with regulatory changes and
efficiency standards
many businesses chose to stay the course
they kept reducing emissions they
continued the transition to electric
vehicles and energy-saving appliances
the ball had been rolling
and it didn't stop
and meanwhile science and technology
continue to advance
so today the price of solar and wind
energy has dropped to the point where in
some places clean energy is cheaper than
fossil fuels
around the world scientists and
entrepreneurs are integrating abundant
renewable energy more powerful batteries
breakthroughs in fields like synthetic
biology to invent a better future that
is
healthier and more affordable
that's all good news for the planet
and it is also good news for people
looking for a job
in the u.s alone more than 3 million
people now work in clean energy related
jobs that is more than the number of
people currently employed by the entire
fossil fuel industry
so despite four years of active
hostility toward climate science
coming from the very top of our federal
government
the american people managed to still
meet
our original commitment under the paris
agreement
and not only that but the rest of the
world stayed in the deal
and now
with president biden
and his administration rejoining the
agreement the u.s government is once
again engaged and prepared to take a
leadership role
and everybody who's been watching john
kerry run around here knows
that we take that role seriously
as the world's second largest emitter of
greenhouse gases
the u.s has to
lead
we have
enormous responsibilities
and obviously we still have a lot of
work to do
but last week congress passed
president biden's bipartisan
infrastructure bill that will among
other things create manufacturing
create jobs manufacturing solar panels
and wind turbines and batteries and
electric vehicles and build out the
first ever national network of charging
stations so families can travel across
the u.s in electric vehicles
and i'm confident that a version of
president biden's buildback better bill
will pass through congress in the coming
next few weeks
and here's what
it will mean when that bill does pass
that legislation will devote over half a
trillion dollars
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
by over a billion metric tons by the end
of the decade at least 10 times more
than any legislation previously passed
by congress
along the way it will reduce consumer
energy costs it will invest in a clean
energy economy it will create hundreds
of thousands of jobs and it will set the
united states on course to meet
its new climate targets
achieving a 50 to 52 reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions below
2005 levels
by 2030.
so the u.s is back
and in moving more boldly
the u.s is not alone
earlier this year
the uk government our hosts
announced a plan to cut emissions by
almost 80 percent by 2035.
this summer the european union put
themselves on a path to carbon
neutrality by 2050.
korea passed a carbon neutrality act in
september that requires the government
to cut greenhouse gas emissions 35
percent or more by 2030.
the canadian government has laid out a
path to carbon neutrality by 2050 with
milestones to hit along the way
so
paris showed the world that progress is
possible created a framework
important work was done there and
important work
has been done here
that is the good news
now for the bad news
we are nowhere near where we need to be
yet
for starters despite the progress that
paris represented most countries have
failed to meet the action plans that
they set six years ago
and the consequences of not moving fast
enough are becoming more apparent all
the time
last month a study found that 85 percent
of the global population has experienced
weather events that were more severe
because of climate change
stronger storms longer heat waves more
intense flooding crippling droughts
parts of the world are becoming more
dangerous to live in
triggering new migration patterns and
worsening conflict around the globe
it's one of the reasons why
the u.s pentagon and other u.s agencies
have said that climate change poses a
national security threat for the u.s and
for everyone else
but not only
did we not hit all of the targets that
were pledged in paris
but remember paris was always supposed
to be a beginning
not an endpoint